hello everybody to Walker here with me
yes me uh-oh sounds like want that name
from Korra this is me this is me and
that's you you know my am you you are me
I have you sit down
um it's uh okay so this is I've done
this a while Legend of Korra uh V logged
as a beginning of season three it's a
three episodes right that they ran
together it it was shown as one episode
but it's technically three yes people on
my Facebook up very confusing like there
were three episodes I saw only one I was
like a but that one was an hour and a
half and each is thirty minutes so they
just typically show the credits in the
mill the episode that again at the end
with the names a little different yeah I
don't know I'm counting it as three um
so yeah so we have uh this is the brand
new beginning here this is uh a breath
of fresh air
yes that is which and as we doesn't feel
like I know as soon as I saw that I'm
like do you think that was intentional
I'm wondering if that was an in-joke
Imam because the rumor is that they they
got rushed on the second season or
something they were planning on one that
Nickelodeon dick them around and like
now do a second season now to be fair
that's a good dicking around like yeah
yeah but apparently like I guess like
they were having trouble like coughing
up a second season really quickly and
it's like well now what do we do cuz we
thought it was only gonna be one so
maybe that was an in-joke like a breath
of fresh air we know what we're doing
now yeah so I mean the that you know if
people ways so I had these mixed
thoughts about legend chorus and people
love it some Haida so very different to
it
um I think we both pretty solidly liked
the first season we my first season up
until last ten minutes and even then
knowing that they probably thought it
was gonna be just one season I was fine
with them like okay I would have ended a
little more vague and differently but I
was fine with it I really liked I first
sees yeah I like the direction I like
the new direction was taking having so
far in the future and then technological
season two's just it wasn't god-awful it
was not a big step backwards yeah I
don't I think it was really cuz when I
think
when I think the season 2 what really
comes in my head is like images and like
spirits and these creative creatures you
know and these like going to the spirit
world and stuff like that and that's not
being really exciting but then if you're
asking me what was it about I couldn't
tell you
like I remember characters I remember
seeing I remember the West your first
avatar more than I remember anything
core with yeah uh is something like I
remember the ending we it was very
Pacific Rim and there was a giant tree
and spirit world and but most everything
I remember is bolin as nuktuk or
whatever and yeah the first avatar
yeah like every was really cool yeah my
story all good ending good and then the
middle is like just like oh we saw this
in season one um so okay so so now we
got this new season this is where you
got the changes happening with the
spirits entering the the human world I
love how they introduced it they show
it's like you know I defeated this you
know giant God practically and I can't
get rid of a bunch of vines and I am
kind of going yeah what that makes no
sense and then when you see a consuming
the cities there go oh and you
immediately see the problem I thought
that was very quick and very clever to
establish uh you know that just this
major problem up the two words colliding
and we said you know this is I'm sure
this is going to be a thing the two
worlds colliding it's going to be tough
and that's gonna be the focus of the
next season you know and I was looking
forward to that um and then it kind of
takes a different turn in a sense it's
and I'm very mixed about it it's like
because they're getting out of the city
which is like great because we spent two
seasons in that city has a beautiful
city but I'm I'm kind of done with it
and if she's pretty much fired from
being the you know keeping balance in
the city because the spirit world is
eating up the human world and the
president things suck as a human world
RUP ting the the spirit world and
neither one's very happy has kind of
expected so he kicked her out I like
that she doesn't quake he kicks her out
but they also find out more airbenders
are showing up so they decide they're
going to leave this either gonna travel
and find these airbenders because the
what the hell is it called the her
moniker merchants once again look at
what the harmonic with its right Miss
Piggy pick her manic energy
harmonic convergence something like that
um having an itching me about the name
send that one to him um and they pretty
much have opened up all these that
airbenders just only people that weren't
airbenders or something air bed well
maybe we don't know what exactly well I
mean that that's what Ramana convergence
seemed Sampson but nobody knows for sure
yet yeah I mean so but that well that's
what they have said so far anything's
possible uh so now we're gonna travel
and they're going to they're trying to
find all these airbenders and they're
trying to recruit them so they can sort
of you could argue this is kind of
selfish where they kind of create the
airbending culture and we create yeah
recreated and it's a strange thing to do
and I'm glad they really addresses like
cuz it on the one hand it almost seems
like a no-brainer well yeah you have
these powers you should come learn how
to use them and to benefit people and
stuff on the other hand it's like no no
you're one of us now you're this culture
you're it's like words of a feather
flock together yeah I mean you you
weren't even born this way you're just
suddenly this and like now you had to be
here you know and you have to be out
you're one of our follow that bird now
that I'm it suddenly hit me and I said
no you should be with us
yeah we're really making follow that
bird references yes oh okay awesome stop
me truck
so uh but then there's other plants
going out there's our stuff there's uh
this real baddie gets his airbending
power and breaks loose he's this big
criminal who wants to bring down the
White Lotus who wants to destroy the
avatar and ease
get the band back together man go get
her man and they all they're pretty cool
so far you have one that has no arms but
she's a waterbender so she uses the
water for arms they're all in RAM foo
panda presents what I was saying each
one more complicated than laughs yeah um
they they come across new characters
that come across a baby Aladdin uh they
come across on the the earth Queen um
who queen bitch yes who you were telling
you you were saying I love how the earth
King that has just barely changed and
changed at all it's all Jiang Zi to say
you know and there is something where
it's always like okay well yes place
will always be corrupt no matter what
you do yeah it's all the people they're
always like you know you're cog oh yeah
like like chorus to you know the legit
chords too different from avatar
something totally different it's like no
this one thing will just never change
they will always be Gotham City there
yeah um Zuko is still alive that was
kind of a shock oh it was awesome and
though not having Dante Bosco's voice -1
for bogus necess it's on half and half
on that because I mean you know we both
love Dante Bosco he's incredible Oh but
even as it all agree if even as an old
man he still get a half that it's you
know it's like this something's got to
change at some point oh they had his
grandson though who looks like he's 40
with the same voice and now they
switched the but I don't know I'm like
this kind of maybe that I was sort of
thinking that too but maybe maybe my
only guess is that maybe they are having
this idea that they're gonna have both
those characters and if you about
everything I guess honestly yeah but you
could have altered his voice like in
pose because it ya know
against you like slowed it down or
something because I've done that before
we yeah ii i ii my saw this with my wife
first up was out um on vacation but the
second I saw the scar we both were like
yes no actually the thing I was more
excited about was that dragon cuz like
we have so dragon sense like they were
learning how to you know the secret of
firebending and and like how such a cute
thing that there's still dragons alive
and then it's like when you just saw one
that was just like whoa like what the
hell's the story behind this I'm the
only thing I was disappointed in this I
was telling you I was like it makes me
worry because if they're bringing Zuko
back I get the sinking feeling we're
gonna have to watch him die somewhere
either in this season or before this
show it's not to be fair we thought he
was dead already
it's okay no I think no I never rumors
and I didn't think it was dead I thought
he was mentioned before but I I was
surprised that he was alive yeah I mean
pretty gay without help yeah like a
season ago so uh the twins are back that
was really great I was amazing
oh that really is like what I wasn't
seeing I was like oh I really like them
Oh for coming bag that'd been exchange
was spectacular just uh why didn't
somebody let us know we have a secret
prison we could throw people in I throw
my tailor in here and then with Zuko's
just like yeah this firebender that you
know can uh bend with his minds like I
used a guy somewhere to try to kill the
Avatar once and then there's like this
awkward silence it didn't work it didn't
work that's okay I tried to kill Korra
for ruining my wedding it happened yeah
I mean just saw these weird awful
conversations um and uh yeah and pretty
much the the earth Queen is pointing her
this army of Earth of airbenders
my guess is to take over the United
Republic because she seemed pissed that
it existed it yeah exactly
um so it's interesting because on the
one hand it's like I guess this is part
of the change that they were talking
about you know the spirit world and the
the human world colliding but unchanged
if they know what they're worth they're
going but but okay the other thing
though is that it specially after the
last season we saw so many spirits and
so many cool things and there
like at the end of the season like
change is gonna be hard but we will make
this happen stuff I'm expecting to see
like you know you saw that golden
hedgehog there for a minute I thought
there's gonna be like 12 of them walking
through the city or something like they
were just gonna be all over the place it
was gonna be more than trying to figure
out how to live with each other it but
it really isn't it's more of this thing
about the airbending which is also good
because it's still the same idea they
had to work with this change this
unexpected is finally a direction that
this show has and I are just like Anka's
no no no no it's like I like it I'll
even say more I really like they bounced
out Korra much more um yeah no good no
no no she's she's still hot she's still
a hothead but it's welcome and it's kind
of deserves my go ahead because she's
taking responsibility for actions and
she's pissed off at the incompetence
around her yeah no I is a queen or the
President or the fact that she's upset
her exactly it's justified when she's
angry even when it's not like when
they're trying to recruit the airbenders
and she says time for a little tough
love you kind of laugh a little cuz you
know it's great we know it's not gonna
go well otaku Kiki Mori guy living in
like the mother's basement yeah and and
you know it's not gonna go well but
you're just sort of looking forward to
and waiting and you know it's not gonna
be like oh she's really gonna fuck up
something big like a whole army is gonna
destroy something cuz I had no it's a
funny she's wearing someone else about
responsibility where was this in season
two hey you have the conversation like
she was such a regression now that we've
got this core of back I'm like it was
like we had core going up and then like
yeah and now she's like back up again
and what yeah and the conversations they
have seem very much like she's you know
she's listening when she's it seems like
she's learning you know this time around
it's like you know she'll still explode
she'll still get angry and stuff but a
it seems justified in being righteous
yeah it is righteous and and see when it
happens you know
to say okay well she's learned something
and she's like okay no fair enough and
you see her balance it out which seems
where she's trying to talk she talks to
the jumper down
she tries talking to Gemini she has a
conversation with Tenzin like the two of
them talk to each other like rational
adults uh I think they may have done
that once in the entire second season
like I can't remember what they either
way yes disowns them early on to the
second half of those like this I'm
pretty sure you practically say like
after watching Korra build herself up in
season one and trying to get a grip on
ourselves this is what I wanted to see
in season two and instead they chucked
it out the window and now that we've got
it back I'm just like oh thank god like
she's way more interesting everybody's
way more interesting though well and the
thing too is they'd be like oh um well
the thing too is that when they go to UM
yeah they pick up Kai uh who's a very
likeable character a new character a is
he's very like a little tough
yeah and I'm saying to myself Tufts are
a little bit yeah yeah I mean he's he's
like a he's like a male version at all
yeah um when he goes off yes uh when he
goes and they take him and they they
find out he's a thief and everything and
I nearly didn't buy that story about the
dead parents I was gonna say like they
say the parents were dead yeah it's like
I don't buy it and then even even for
this shows get a little sappy and I'm
like something's not right here and the
second people showed up I'm like okay
he's wanted yeah um but if I play his
local character and you know they say no
I trust him let's follow him through on
this you know and Marco doesn't trust
amazed like you know I'm gonna be
watching you and stuff like that and the
first thing comes in my head is okay we
gotta wait five episodes or so before he
notes next episode yeah just boom it
happens right away well I know I still
think he's gonna betray the daughter
like they're gonna have something going
on he's gonna let her down or something
that that's my prediction my early
predictions see he's in prison I don't
know how far they're gonna take that I
mean know that it'll be like something
else but no but that's one say yeah I
like that it's like very quickly they
get that out of the way and they have
fun with it I love him robbing the
person and then like going to a hotel
and living the
life and everything he's like a little
Macaulay Culkin Running Room yeah
anybody that's fair me home alone - um
this is caught the fault like to make a
prison food
can you imagine you know I wouldn't ever
do that cuz the boys headed there you
know because it is airbending yeah maybe
we our bags can do that um that'd be fun
keep get on that um but yeah so the uh
and for me it's like my favorite thing
is very much the characters even though
season two was kind of a mess it's like
I love I love the twins you know and I
love the the spirits that came in I sort
of loved these on a character or the you
got time or attentions family and stuff
you know I love seeing more of the
character um so the idea green character
now is clicking in a way they didn't in
season two well if you had bits of
characters clicking at one time or
another but compared to season two I
feel like these first three episodes
like everybody is in a groove and a
rhythm there's nobody there I'm just
like they're annoying me they're boring
me I've got issues with this everyone
the villains
Korra Asami maka I love ma Co in this
weird phase now where he doesn't know
what to do and by the way on top of that
it might be only one who thinks that
Asami and Cora are the better couple I
doubt I doubt they're gonna have the
balls to go through them but I'm like
they're actually a cuter couple than
Korra well I honestly I don't even want
to see him as that really cuz I like the
but now you come on okay okay it does
but you know this is saying I to really
like them as a friendship I think
actually they're like you're right
they're very woodsy darts off as a
friend and I grows into something newer
Oh IIIi think they work in the
friendship III why do you have to ruin
my face
but but no something you bring it up I
think is very true is that this is very
much a team it's a group I think my
favorite thing that it just felt the
most like you know avatar last airbender
and it was also funny is when they're
travelling trying to convince people to
come aboard you see that little icon of
them traveling you just see with the
skateboard Feynman by the end of their
eyes and it gets more and more sad by
the end and I was realizing that is I
think a big part what I was missing in -
in season 2 that was in season 1 but
night not as much even here uh which is
the group in all these characters to get
these characters you really like are
together and they're working off each
other and they're interacting I'm sorry
thinking about like how often did you
see just all of them go on an adventure
all of them go somewhere you really did
part of it too is how much time was
wasted rehashing the same stuff in
season 2 yeah I mean I get what happened
I think they got under the wire they
they had planned for one season almost
and they're like crap and you have to
basically almost just come up with
filler because you're just like I don't
know what to do yet and it's obvious
they've worked out and I'm hoping
this'll last because it seems to me at
least by these first three episodes
they've worked out the kinks like okay
we know what we're doing now we've got
we've got the groove we've got whatever
but the writing in these three episodes
compared to season two is really tight
and yet what's weird is just like how
much actually really happened when you
look at Cora's side of the story not a
ton but the way they intercut that with
breaking the other villains loose with
ma CO and Bolin finding their parents
with finding Kai like they managed to
take something we're not a lot of shit's
really happening and paste it in such a
way that it's still really interesting
well that is something I noticed about
these three episodes is that it did seem
much slower than and then even last
airbender or the other two seasons and I
was kind of noticing it but I was like
see for me it felt like it was paced
more like nice but at the same time I
said I you know I trust them I feel
comfortable with this you know I'm like
I'm fine just seeing them sort of work
out you know what they're gonna do
where they're gonna go just sort of
talking and which is something I like I
know I've had this disagreement of some
people I like season one of last
airbender because I kind of liked that
there was kind of this slow methodical
pace that we're just kind of gonna
figure this out as we go along what I
think I think the big thing the reason I
think worked a little bit better in
avatars because there was I think this
comes from that they they were kids and
that yet to train more like a kids show
uh but is a vanish there's much more
energy and but now we have a more but
part of it too is they have a more
open-ended journey now the thing is in
season one you had to fight amon you
have a clearly defined villain a
political thriller plot it just launches
itself into it season two is weird
because it started off so like tight to
the point that it was yeah busy so much
stuff happened in that those first
couple of episodes yeah I like a rush I
was really excited and then it just
ground to a halt
and like I would rather do it this way
where it's a little slow a little
methodical from the beginning but seems
to know where it's going versus we're
gonna throw a whole bunch of shit at you
in the first two episodes and then we're
just gonna wander around and 100 circles
regress our characters now to where
we're going to last you episodes which
will be amazing well and that yeah
that's pretty much what I'm thinking you
know cuz as I'm watching it because I
remember the the opening of season 1 the
opening season 2 and they were really
strong openings and you know even though
they have some problems to say they were
really strong and there was this sense
of oh my god I'm excited I can't wait to
see more of this show uh and then
especially season 2 you know there's
sort of it got really bumpy insists or
let you down well it really sees like
it's Alec Season one I like to really
kind of went bumpy and let you down in
the survey areas until it came back at
the end uh and this one yeah it's just
sort of this it's not like boom here we
go getting ready here we go it's just
this very slow mellow pace well and
that's how I edit art started out it was
they found egg and
then yeah I think my vibration comes in
give them up and it but it's still
slow-moving it's on this kind of steady
track of you know get him damn you it's
in the other person so to add some
pretty it's some pretty good you know it
compared everything else maybe now it's
gonna say it's some really good solid
action but the more thing about its like
maybe if I look back at episode wouldn't
be quite as major as I remember because
we've seen so much and it liked it
because it did have sort of a methodical
pace so but yeah that's what I'm saying
I'm saying that if if it keeps going
this direction or this is bride the
birth direction the go to start off
small and just keep building that's what
last airbender didn't I generally prefer
that I thought I thought overall episode
one of Korra or season one not as well
as avatar but was doing kind of that I
thought season two though just threw
everything at the wall to see what would
stick and then just it just fell apart
well yeah could and it's no wonder in
the last three episodes so which were
really strong but i sat there through
all that middle part of the season going
what where are we going because everyone
was telling me on my facebook you guys
are telling me it's like you know man
the first three episodes totally just
makes up for the season two it does
something of doing and so I was really
expecting something kind of along the
lines of the intro of season two so when
I saw this I was like oh that's not what
I expect is that Chicago there is actual
character but the same time I was like
yeah I really don't know who these
people are Lana or they're going I want
know like they're setting up these
characters we don't know everything
about these games are interacting in an
interesting way having the conversations
like adults approaching things like
adults not know what something about
season two is that even though I like a
lot of characters and to you sort of God
of just boom right away like in the
first episode you sort of know what
they're doing what they're about and
this one you're kind of not entirely
sure you kind of like well what is the
backstory somebody on there dropping a
little bits and pieces here but you
don't tirely know um so yes I really
like
and it was a very different direction I
thought it was going to be but again
think even more about it if they want
the direction with the spirits where
it's like all the spirits are walking
with the people and stuff like that
it would kind of be a retread of season
two because that had so many spirits in
it water here's the other darlin I don't
think they were abandoning that plot
entirely because she's gonna have to go
back at some point and fix the city like
that's not going to fix itself and my
guess is somehow this earth kingdom war
that seems to be brewing she's the queen
queen bitch faces like queen resting
bitchface is building a secret army like
I think that's gonna somehow collide
with what's going on in the city like I
I don't know yet but I'm hoping you know
we can bring back Prince Iroh or general
Iroh mm-hmm they can have it like one
big thing at the end like that would be
fun so now with Zuko I'm psyched I'm so
safe there is a what I was noticing too
just in these three episodes the the
animation in it I was saying by god this
animation was saved for like the last
four episodes of last airbender like
they had to throw so much into it and
now it's like just commonplace animation
because it's so good I mean the
backgrounds don't need to look you know
it's the painted backgrounds and they're
moving in so much of it like you didn't
even need to CG Nickelodeon what he did
that off your ass and throw money at the
series yeah good well and I like the
animation of season two actually I uh
there's a deal I didn't like it but I
thought it was kind of a different style
for the spirits I felt it worked here
we're getting back much more into like
you know the mountains and the clouds
and the solid textures and stuff and
they're they really work it honestly is
nice to see you earth Kingdom again -
well I'll say it reminds me of very much
of old school well now old school uh
Disney Animation with like the painted
backgrounds that they would make CG and
just move it just a little bit but that
that little movement still made it seem
new your watch more anime it just looks
like every time
no no it's an anime too but but there's
still a style - there's still something
- you know it's anime for Americans and
you know the American even though it's
animated by Japanese you probably um
actually think the Korean Korean okay uh
I might be wrong on that I'm sure
someone's gonna cut but you have a Hana
main you have American animation like
you know let's let's say Disney
animation and anime uh the Styles you
know they're very similar they do so the
same thing with the painted backgrounds
that they can make 3d um it's still
different I mean especially with you
know in anime they there's so much focus
on what they do the fight scenes they're
saving up for that so we have a lot
closer to the eyes you know and not the
mouth talking so that we can focus and
they're done very strategically and
they're done very well but the same time
there's a new movement that depends on
the anime though you get a short
12-episode anime you can get some pretty
complicated animation oh no you can tell
some of these never is they're not as
obsessive about the fluidity like they
are in um Western animation but I mean
it's not all close-ups and motion oh no
no no and honestly even when they do I'm
saying they actually do a very effective
way very cleverly because I've seen
shows from Japan with animation like
this no but I'm saying there is a it
American animation has this thing uh
maybe with flash animation that might be
going down to be I'm not sure but just
constant sort of movement I mean they're
always like you can't have a person just
sit here and move their mouth and maybe
their eyes just for a while it's like
they have to move like this or they have
to go like this or they constantly have
to move a little bit a little bad girl
not in Korra though there are times like
but I mean it's also a TV show so you're
never going to get that super from a TV
I mean for a Nickelodeon American
children's drama you know and I don't
think any kid really would probably
follow this you know what the animation
is good I don't know where he's going
with this no no that's why I said no I
was just saying it really reminds me
it's sort of like watching a mix between
an anime and like a Disney film brought
to your TV and I just can't believe
again that Nickelodeon is bringing us
this uh you know cuz it does just look
so good even the stories I'm thinking to
myself you know no kid that watches
spongebob is gonna follow this topic at
all you know where we have punished Bob
we're still going with that reference oh
well I watched Nickelodeon well this is
on Nickelodeon
um san-chan Greg okay
that is a lot it's great okay sounds
like an even better reference um so no
it's just one of those things were it's
the AMEX she's just beautiful as that's
why I'm getting to and it's one of those
where even though like even though the
prisons are designed great um and yeah
it just feels like something like really
getting back to sort of those really
wide open landscapes again and you know
and seeing that ship fly over and you
see the clouds go by you see the mouths
you see even the the earth Kingdom you
know the the city you know now that it's
in the CG as well I mean it just looks
so much grander and bigger
um so I'm really impressed when I'm just
really impressed with how they've
incorporated the hand-painted
backgrounds with the computer animation
I think they just blend together just so
perfectly I fingers crossed they finally
got it two seasons but they finally got
it like I this is the first time I feel
like this is getting last airbender
worthy like none other
cute will followed but like I feel like
no this is feeling like I'm almost
watching avatar last airbender the
characters are clicking the stories
interesting it's no traveled on yeah
they're battling god I hope they keep
this up I really do cuz and like I
there's people out there just like I
love people reply in my facebook know
after that last season I won't even try
it's just not worth it made me cry with
I'm like your loss go ahead because I'm
like these three episodes were great no
I I mean they could totally disappoint
the crap out of all and this but let's
be honest these guys at their worst is
still better than like
oh yeah it's best you know it's still so
much more interesting and so much more
fun I could have been watching
transformers for it instead I stay home
than watch it I guess I perfect we I
purposely did this first cuz I was on
vacation I don't got the Transformers
for yet but I know I'm like know if I'm
doing anything I'm watching fucking core
I don't give a shit about transfer I
mean I gotta see it you must be my
reaction you know but it's like I don't
give a shit it's like I want to see this
and that this I'm doing first so uh yeah
any follow-ups on it or any questions
any answers any clue no avatar
come back that's a lock of dead